who is the strongest Avenger in your
opinion who do you think will win in a
fight if everyone fought epu would it be
Thor would it be uh well I mean I I uh
I'm biased but you have awesome powers I
have really really good Powers I don't
know why Ant-Man when I was a boy wasn't
as popular as the other ones because the
Ant-Man had awesome [__] Powers when
I was when I was filming Ant-Man for the
first time there was a moment when I got
to hang out a little bit with Stan Lee
yes I was gonna and this was the coolest
day ever and we were sitting it was the
day that he came in to shoot his Cameo
and we were sitting by the monitors and
he said I'm so happy that they're making
Ant-Man into a film
and uh he said the reason is I always
had this Vision uh of Ant-Man
and every time you would read about him
in the comic book you could never really
gauge the size it just doesn't work with
panels in a car in a comic you can't
tell how small it is you can't you don't
have anything there's no reference and
so he said with a movie you really will
be able to see the way I envisioned it
which I've never really seen envisioned
in the way that I'd kind of imagined I
love this behind the scenes stuff you um
on tell me if it's true on Avengers you
got a hold of uh Captain America's
shield in other words he hands it to the
PA or somebody right and you say hey
PA give me that [__] Shield I'm gonna
hold it yeah you were shocked it was
heavier than you thought it's heavy yeah
well it's it's it yeah yeah it um it is
impossible to not be it's kind of caught
up in all of yeah all of the stuff I
mean I remember we were shooting end
game and and it's like wow there's the
gauntlet yeah and uh there's Thor's
hammer you get genuinely excited yes I
would too I I mean all of the
memorabilia all of the stuff all of this
stuff that I know is like in kind of
ingrained in people's Consciousness is
there a problem when you're filming a an
iconic thing like that where you go [__]
maybe I should grab something maybe I
should take uh my uh my hand I just
assume I assume they're just monitoring
everything they do and I know because
you can't yeah it would be real it would
be a real bad move to try and pocket a
shield that pocket but would you be a
douchebag if you went up to them and
said oh can I keep my Ant-Man uh I've
done it I did it what do you have I have
an Ant-Man helmet are you shocked when
you see yourself in those movies because
I imagine there's so much green screen
special effects and everything in a way
of course you're a man probably half the
[__] you shoot you're imagining
you see it for the first time when you
see the movie sometimes like that end
game that you know that whole sequence
it was like oh my God so this is what it
looks like and you you do kind of have
to imagine certain things but there's
also and it's amazing it's incredible I
mean they've got really talented people
dude are you talking about when people
start disappearing and stuff yeah yeah
it was really um it's it's cool to see
it's cool to see because you know you
work on something but it's still nice
when you see the movie to be surprised
yeah
foreign